countries around the globe are marking
100 years since the end of the first
world war heads of state and dignitaries
from over 70 nations are in Paris for
the centenary commemorations and we can
cross live to our correspondents who
were there for us first
- Daniel Hawkins who and inshallah
Dubinski who's waiting for us they're
both live from the French capital at
Daniel first a day to reflect and
remember what's still ahead in Paris
yeah indeed over 70 world leaders in
attendance here in the French capital
marking at a hundred years since the end
of that war 20 million dead 20 more
million injured over four years or one
of the most bloodiest conflicts in
history Putin himself was a little late
to the remembrance ceremony he didn't
arrive at the palace theorists say Trump
also being delayed for other reasons as
well nonetheless the two leaders shaking
hands exchanging exchanging hellos at
the ceremony at the Arc de Triomphe just
about an hour or so ago now the
speculation of what exactly happened
behind the scenes has been rife now for
some days and weeks we'll the two
presidents meet on the sidelines of this
of this event will they not the American
side had been shopping and changing
plans for quite some time at first
jordan bolton said that the Americans
did favor some sort of meeting some sort
of bilateral talks later saying that any
sort of such event would be very brief
before finally saying that it was highly
unlikely to happen the Kremlin also
speaking about the possibility of a
working lunch which was taking place
just here behind me at the palace the
Elysee where Putin Trump R actually sat
next to each other it has been confirmed
that though mr. Putin did give a comment
to RT France exclusively saying that
there will be no talks as such stating
that they will take place instead at g20
however he said that the Russian side is
always open to dialogue and what's an
improvement in relations as do the
Americans it's perhaps speculated that
the reason behind this Trump maybe
didn't want to detract the tension from
this main event or to irritate the host
president macron by devoting time
especially to bilateral talks with his
Russian counterpart the two leaders
despite their differences didn't meet
yesterday they put on a show of unity
which was clear at least in their body
language
[Music]
terrific two years I wanted to welcome
Rachele authority between alternations
the main remembrance event of course
took place just about an hour half or so
ago the leaders making their way back
into the palace to illustrate behind me
for that working lunch a macron didn't
meet Chancellor Merkel yesterday though
for a separate event another wreath
laying ceremony at a memorial during
which there was a bit of a comical
moment due to a slight tear perhaps
mix-up of identity have with sharks
about angular Merkel
[Music]
all that focus on behind-the-scenes
diplomacy all the speculation on
closed-door talks is now all but over
which is perhaps for the best of course
given the main aim of this gathering of
leaders here in Paris that is of course
to commemorate and remember those who
gave their lives in conflict and perhaps
of course as well to make some headway
and some of the key international issues
of the day as well indeed thank you for
that that's Daniel Hawkins now also in
Paris for is is Charlotte Dubinsky now
Charlotte may have been a touchy-feely
show of affection between Makran and
Donald Trump there but not everyone's
pleased about Trump's participation
there he tell us more well that's why
many people very unhappy that Trump is
here for that commemoration over a
hundred years since the end of the first
world war this is of course the first
foreign trip he's made since those
midterm elections and as you can see
behind me hundreds of people have turned
out here in Paris to protest against
that visit by Donald Trump saying he's a
man who makes war with anyone so it
seems an idealistic that he would be
here trying to commemorate the end of
that great war a hundred years ago now
this isn't the only protest that we've
seen in Paris today in fact there was a
protester against directly against
President Trump as his motorcade was
making its way to that Armistice
ceremony with a female protester running
out in front of that motorcade with the
words fake peacemaker written all over
her body that was when he was all over
his way into that so many now the other
interesting thing that's going on here
is the tensions that we've seen between
the leaders of the US and of France it's
been an uncomfortable few days of the
macron give an interview in which he
said that the USA was also a threat to
Europe and as such Europe needed to
create its own defense force to
strengthen its security here now Trump
reacted to that by criticizing what
magcon said and also described it as in
something this is what is tweet said
president McCrone of France has just
suggested that Europe build its own
military in order to protect itself from
the US China and Russia very insulting
but perhaps Europe should first pay its
fair share of NATO which the u.s.
subsidizes greatly well there has in the
past being a bit of a bromance between
Trump and macro and Trump was here at
just over a year ago and they had a very
strong relationship but after that tweet
and a number of other instances it seems
that that relationship was soured
somewhat Makhan tried to smooth it over
saying that he agreed with President
Trump that Europe needed to pay more
into the NATO budget the European
security today being assured just finds
the United States and we need a much
better appreciate what you're saying
about Britain sharing you know what my
attitudes been and we want a strong
Europe it's very important to us a
strong Europe and whichever way we can
do it the best and most efficient well
this protest is due to go on for the
next few hours against that visit of
President Trump also many people here
hijacking the protester protest against
some of macrons own policies in his own
country
particularly a group behind me who are
actually protesting against what they
see as being the closure of the
frontiers here in Europe and the removal
of migrants from camps such as in Calais
but the main part most people are here
to tell President magcon I present
Mekons guest president Trump that he is
just not welcome here in France and as
one TV reporter said early this week he
should just go home okay Charla thank
you for bringing us the latest from
those protests also spotted behind you
there that Trump balloon again that we
also saw during protests in London is
becoming almost an iconic trumpet effigy
isn't it but thank you for now that's
Daniel Hawkins on shala dude Dubinski
both in Paris for us today
you